[inaudible]
all right, here we go guys.
I got a Peterson. I gotta
Shapiro. I gotta Weinstein.
I got a Rubin. I feel I should go to you
first be screened using the Canadian.
Yeah, that's, I saw that
movie. It was pretty good and
not bad. All right. You're,
you're on real time tonight.
And I thought, yeah,
it's an interesting little piece of all
of this because we're sort of all out of
the mainstream, but we kind of
dance in there every now and again.
You probably dancing. They're a
little more than the rest of us. Uh,
you're gonna smack around
Marta tonight or what?
You know, I, I'm, I'm, I think that
it'll probably be pretty, pretty cordial.
[inaudible] I think that Mara is secretly
one of us now, and maybe I'm wrong,
but I think the, I think that
Myra is tired of the, I mean,
his show was called politically incorrect.
I mean,
I think that he is tired
of the identity politics.
I think he's tired of the
intersectional nonsense.
I think that he wants to have
some open conversations. Uh,
I just think that he is,
he's tied politically left,
so I'll be interested to see how
much of that he goes after you know,
how much Trump talk there is,
which I find utterly uninteresting is
the roof and how much of it will be about
kind of broader issues of,
of freedom,
of speech and a and civility
and having decent conversations.
So I think that he's on the right
side of those issues. I mean I've,
I've played him on my show ran and
I disagree with them on everything
politically,
but I play clips of him
on my show specifically on
those issues and him cracking
the whip on people on the
identity politics nonsense.
And I think we're on the same page.
Well, if he wants to be an
effective advocate for the left,
he should lead the march and dissociating
the moderate left from the radical
unreasonable left someone's gotta do
it because the strategy that they're
abiding by right now is
pretty damn self destructive.
And he's in a good position to do that.
And I think he's motivated to do
it because he is a free speech guy.
Being a comedian and everything.
It's risky,
I think.
I think you take your life in your hands
if you're the leftist who says that
right now, if you're the person
on the left who does this mean?
You did it and survived, but you, but
that's probably tired from the left.
That's right. You also, you
can try it. You found it,
you found a bunch of new
friends. Right? I mean that's,
that's really what people have
to understand is that when you,
when you take these positions,
yes,
they're going to be a lot of people
who decide that you are Satan.
But there's going to be a whole lot of
people who are, who are your new friends,
who are, who are ready to
have these conversations,
which is why, you know, again,
this sort of IDW termed the,
that Eric coin is so fascinating because
everyone disagrees with everyone about
nearly everything in this group.
Um,
but because we don't want to
shut down the conversation,
it's created this whole audience for
every one of us, like each one of us,
our audience has increased tremendously
just by being part of conversations with
one another.
So that's,
that's it to me.
What is it that you guys think about
us and this wider world? Can I do it?
Come on. Just the awesomeness
and the amazing given all that,
but like about likeminded
that we just happen
to be the examples that are sitting here
that it is okay for all the differences
that we've talked about
on I'm gay marriage and
abortion and death penalty and
all of these things that I know we
all have various disagreements on.
Why are we all okay with that?
And so many people outside of
this seemed to not be okay. Well,
I think it has to do with the fact
that most of us are confident.
There's a sort of a principle of,
um, faith in rationality that,
uh,
I'm not that worried about a lot of
the things that the far left is very
concerned about because I have an idea
that more or less if you do the reason
correctly, the reasoning correctly, uh,
everything is going to
work out pretty much. Okay.
And I think that we have the
dexterity in changing our minds,
um,
admitting when we're wrong,
when we've changed our perspective and
stealing each other's ideas and giving
credit. So that I have a
sense that if I'm, you know,
Ben and I have not gone toe to
toe on a abortion, for example.
And I have an idea of the
outlines of his position.
He probably has some idea of mine.
Um,
but my guess is is that he's not going
to go bananas on spermicide and I'm not
going to be advocating for the
right to abort a child, uh,
a day before it's due date. Um, and, uh,
except for extraordinary circumstances.
And even then, I'm not sure,
but I think what it is is a certain kind
of confidence that you can allow the
other person in a discussion to actually
have a genuine position and that you
can contend with it.
And what we need to do is to push out
more of the cognitive Lego that gives us
that confidence to more
people so that they can say,
I don't need to fear the district.
You know,
pro choice and pro life are both
really limited positions in my opinion.
And it's just an example of one
of many things that we have.
We have gained the confidence with each
other that we're not going to devolve
into name calling if everybody,
uh,
plays in an honest fashion
and uses the full focus.
That's where it is. I mean, the honest
fashion things. I think what counts.
I asked him about this earlier, so I was
just doing a podcast with Sam, right?
Because we all hang out together because
[inaudible] seven people lunch with his
mother was more important than us
events. But, uh, you know what,
what I asked him about this and what
Sam said is that he thinks that what,
what has changed is that there's,
there's a bunch of us who are not
interested in the stupidest version of the
argument, right? So if, if, if I want
to hear in a pro choice argument,
I want to hear the most sophisticated
version of the pro choice argument and
then see if I make an
argument against that.
I don't want the simplistic
version of the pro choice argument,
just so I can knock down the simplistic
version of the prototype. Sorry. We, yes,
it makes for a great venture period
destroys video. Right? But is it,
but it's more fun for me,
like personally,
I really much more enjoy engaging with
the best ideas that somebody else has to
offer. Then engaging with the, the worst
ideas that you can pick out of a hat.
That's really, well. So I mean, one
of the things that was useful for me,
for example, in this protracted
discussion with Sam is that my arguments,
my arguments are better now
than they were. And he might say, well,
why do you care if your
arguments are better?
And the reason I care about whether my
arguments are better is because I know
that my arguments are part of the toolkit
that I use to operate effectively in
the world.
Like arguments aren't just
some abstraction that you
hold that's disconnected
from your actions in the world.
And if my arguments are
more fine tuned and sharper,
and if I'm able to and to our account
for a wider range of phenomena because
someone has put forward facts that
were hard for me to incorporate,
then my tool is much more efficient and
I can operate more effectively in the
world. So I find it, well it's a, it's
a variant of, of, of your position.
It's like I want to hear the best versions
of the arguments that run counter to
mine because I'd like to figure out
where I'm wrong and I'd like to make what
I'm doing better.
And that's more important to me.
It is literally more important to me
then making sure that what I already know
is right. How come? I'm
confident in what I know,
but I also know that I could do a better
job of expressing it. That it could be,
it could be the system
could be more dynamic,
it could take more think
more things into account.
Like I've got plenty to learn and a real
discussion with someone who objects to
you. That's where you learn.
So, so more power to that.
I would say that I think
there's pretty easy test,
which is when someone catches you out on
a part of the argument that you've made,
that you, that you know was flawed
and someone catches you out,
do you smile or you get angry writing,
it really is almost that easy because
the truth is that there is something fun
about the idea of having to rethink
your position and something adventurous
about the idea that you haven't
thought everything through.
That there are these new vistas of
thought that maybe you haven't considered
before and it does hone you.
It makes you better at it and it,
it also allows you to listen.
Life is funny and it's funny that we're
flawed human beings that are logic is
flawed.
So there's certain humor to the idea
that somebody is exposing a rift in your
thinking that you know have to deal with
it. It's what makes life fun. If you,
if you were just a stone all the time,
it'd be really boring.
We kinda got there cause when
we did the abortion discussion,
my position basically I
think is similar to yours,
which is that at 20 weeks where they've
shown that the fetus can feel pain,
that to me is the cutoff. I described
myself as begrudgingly pro choice.
But you said to me,
well if you're acknowledging that it's
a life at 20 well then it's obviously a
life at 18 now to be completely
cogent in my argument,
I have to concede that point to you.
It didn't,
it didn't move me to tell you that I'm
going to now agree with you on this,
on what the policy should be.
But we can do that and we didn't punch
each other after and, and it's all right.
You know, and then what if somebody
comes in and says, well, you know,
life or not life is a boolean.
And the problem is in computer science
is one of casting, which is if you,
if you make it a float and you're
talking about the degree of life or the
meaning of the life of the quality of
the life and does that change things?
And so,
you know,
this idea about may I break your frame
while I'd prefer if we stayed in it for a
little while,
but then let's explore that in a second.
And so there's sort of
a generosity of spirit,
um, argument. And I think
that quite frankly, um,
one of the strangest things about
this group of people is that I find it
spectacularly non egoic in
terms of when we have a dinner.
Um, I don't have a sense that
anybody needs to lead. I mean,
it's as close as I've seen like a
round table where the sheer pleasure of
talking to people at a ta in a time.
This is a McCarthy like time.
And we have,
I feel so happy to be at a table in
which I can talk about things that are
troubling me or bring out something that
I worry that says something negative
about myself,
that I'm having these thoughts that nobody
wants to be booted out of the group,
um, by virtue of grand standing. And
I think that, that, that kind of, um,
it's really interesting watching people
who would be thought of as being highly
ago behaving in a ongoing fat.
It's,
I think that part of that too is one of
the things Dave and I have talked about
and the technology is enabling this,
is that because I've looked at
this group and thought, well,
why in the world did it ever
get categorized as a group?
Because it's a strange
group and there's some,
there's some reasons pretty much everybody
who's in it is entrepreneurial in the
fundamental sense in that everybody's
created their own little domain and it's
Kinda hard to knock them over because
they're in their domain. So we're not,
I'm reliant in some important sense on
external funding, let's say, to, to,
to, to enable us to continue. So that
gives us a certain amount of freedom.
But another part of it is
that as far as I can tell,
everybody who's participated believes
that their audience is intelligent.
And I think that that's also a
reflection of that it's, it's,
it's not lack of
intellectual self confidence.
It is lack of commitment
to your set of ideas.
I guess if they're axiomatically true,
but that spills over to the
attitude towards the audience.
Like I don't feel that I'm there to tell
my audience a bunch of things that they
need to know that I already know when
I'm conducting my tour. It's like,
well here's a bunch of ideas that I'm
confused about still and I'm gonna use
this as an opportunity to explore them
and I'm going to explore them with you
and you guys are going to come along
for the ride and that's going to be good
for everyone.
I really saw that with Harris in Vancouver
because we had a well as high level
an intellectual discussion
as we could manage.
And I would say it was approximately
at the same level as a good phd defense
when when the defense is going well and
the audience was with us the whole way
and they're participating
in this discourse process,
far more important to participate in
the process of discourse then to specify
the outcome.
And the audience had made that decision
and abided by it while we were,
while we were
the discretion describing. I think that
that's, that is the difference between,
I think that's why like Joe
Rogan, for example, is so popular.
When I listened to Joe,
I know he's going on an intellectual
journey that's going to take three hours.
I don't know where the
destination is going to write,
but I know that the attorney is
going to be a lot of fun. Yeah.
And I think that that's, that's what
makes for success in this, in this field.
And so much of,
of our politics,
so much of our intellectual life has
become what you're talking about standing
on a stage and people yelling at you
what you ought to think if they're a good
person. Right, exactly. And, and,
and it's, it's, it's no fun. I mean,
it's a lot. Julia was the same
thing that great authors do.
It's like a distinction between
Dostoevsky and Ayn rand. It's like,
you know where round is going to
aunt right from the beginning.
Whereas if you read a dusty yefsky novel,
you have no damn idea where that's
going to come out. And neither did he.
So he was exploring the ideas in
formulating them as he went along.
And that's true art. And that is what
Rogan does is that, you know, and,
and he's very good at that because he's
a smart guy who isn't afraid of the fact
that there's a whole bunch
of things he doesn't know.
And so he can lead people on that journey.
And the journey is more important
than to use a terrible cliche.
The journey is more important
than the destination.
Yeah. I think you're gonna use a tiny
time. We have to get on to other points.
But the one thing I would add,
um,
which is a dangerous idea is that I think
there is a concept of good diversity
in bed diversity, which is not
understood in the general population. Um,
good diversity is when you
have a collection of people
with different ideas and
they're somehow complimenting each other
and checking each other and people are
backing down and seeing things that
they wouldn't have seen because you're
walking around the elephant from all
the different sides and seeing all the
different components.
Bad diversity is something like two people
grow up in different countries. One,
one drives on the left side of the road,
one drives on the right side of the road.
And the idea is that you decide that,
uh,
everybody should be able to drive on the
same side of the road that they grew up
on. And so instead of everybody getting
to a really interesting panel, uh,
you get a lot of auto accidents and
nothing really interesting happens.
And so I think it's very important
to be honest that there is a lack of
diversity about what
constitutes conversation.
And I think that that's a
very troubling thing because,
um, we, there's no precedent for
discussing bad diversity at the moment,
which is I would much rather listen
to, to theologians talking, uh, and,
and building up a some
high structure and to, uh,
atheist astrophysicist talking
about the same thing than having two
conversations of an atheist
and an astrophysicist way
each of them keeps tearing
down each other starting assumptions
and you come back eight hours later and
nothing has been achieved. But does that
kind of explain your success in a way?
Cause probably four years
ago in conservatives were
basically only talking to
conservatives the way the left seems to
only be talking to itself these days.
You started doing a little of this
and I would venture to guess that you
probably in a way,
feel more comfortable with this crew who
you disagree with on a gajillion things.
Then probably when you're hanging out
with just a bunch of conservatives that
you're like, yeah, we
all agree on this stuff.
I think that the,
the idea that I,
the phone conversations are the ones
where you're surprised and I think we have
yet to have a group conversation or even
in conversation one on one cause we all
talk,
you know,
one on one to each other to where
something surprising doesn't get said. Uh,
and that, that makes everything
a lot more interesting and fun.
And right now I got to say everything
is so boring. Like for all the chaos,
everything is so boring because it just,
it breaks down into a trouble.
[inaudible] court does business.
I mean it really,
it really is just everybody feels like
everything is spun out of control,
but everybody's hunkered
down in their own bunker.
And so everything comes down to Trump
has always right or Trump is always wrong
and we're all supposed
to revolve around this,
this black hole that is Trump or the
sun that is Trump and he's the center of
gravity.
I don't think most people live their
lives thinking about these problems.
And the whole Trump attack and Trump
defense thing is really dull. I mean,
when I went on Mars show,
there was the youtube part afterwards and
the panelists with the exception of me
were tearing Trump apart.
And I was sort of watching that
from the outside in some sense.
Partly because I'm a Canadian.
And I thought, well first of all,
it's just not that interesting
that you can list Trump's faults.
It's like you and you
and my crazy neighbor.
It's like you're not bringing anything
to the table doing that. It's too easy.
And then of course the other problem
is while by going after Trump,
you're going after his supporters,
hypothetically speaking.
And of course that's
50% of your population,
which turns out to be a very big
strategic problem for you. You know,
now and in the future. So it
is dull and, and, and I don't,
I don't think people are,
are,
people would rather have a
more interesting conversation.
That's what we can offer to so don't,
so that's what I wanted.
Where I wanted to take this.
How do we,
I mean we hit on this a little
bit in the first two hours,
but how do we do that now?
How do we lay out,
I think we're already laying out
a more interesting conversation,
but how do we also lay out something
that doesn't make everyone feel horrible?
Because that is a lot
of what's going on here.
All of these people that are showing
up to your events, they're going, wow,
what a reprieve from the madness.
I mean,
I haven't been able to do that
politically. I wouldn't say,
I mean what I've been suggesting
to people is that, um,
as intolerable as they find their lives
for reasons that are arbitrary and self
inflicted,
there are things that they could do at
the individual level that will make a
radical improvement.
They're difficult things.
There are things that require the adoption
of responsibility and vision and the
willingness to,
to speak your partial and imperfect truth.
But if you put that into
practice, there is a nap. Now,
one of the things that needs to be done
in the political sphere is to delineate
what that app might look like politically.
You know,
to give people something that's
positive to strive for it.
While I mentioned earlier that I see
that to some degree in the burgeoning
literature that's suggesting that many
things around the world are improving
very rapidly. You know, and
your counter position was,
well that doesn't mean our situation isn't
fragile, which I also agree with but,
but there is reason I think there is
genuine reason to be optimistic about the
future at a sociological
and political level.
And I think that that's something
that we could be having a more serious
discussion about.
So
[inaudible] people I think.
I think that's right.
I also think that um,
you know,
what the reason that you've
been so successful is because
while you are speaking
in,
in kind of terms about society reads it
as self help and everybody reads it a
self help.
And I think that pretty much all of us,
what we are saying is
being read as self help.
And I think that that's empowering because
basically we're saying to people is,
for the most part it's a free country.
Like shut up and get on with your lives.
Just assault. There's a bumper
sticker that was going around,
you know that the Shapiro 2020 years for
2024 bumper stickers with the something
I tend on the show, which was solve
your own problems. Right? Which is to,
because we're all looking for other
veterans. One better than that.
It doesn't solve your own
problems. It's, it's three things.
Solve your own problems.
You can solve your own problems and you'll
find the deepest meaning in your life
if you decide that you're going to
solve your own phrase. Actually,
I know that's a nice combination. I think
that message is for the vast amount.
Like even when you're talking
about societal problems,
the very emphasis on reason is a
suggestion that you can solve a lot of the
problems in your life if you
change how you're thinking.
I think we are engaged in a collective
form of cognitive behavioral therapy.
I think that everybody is depressed and
we don't know why we're depressed and
we're upset when we don't
really know why we're upset.
I was saying my wife the other day,
if you w w a couple of things.
So I say my wife the other day,
if you were in 19 three and he's,
someone just dropped you in 2018 you would
think, my God, this is heaven lately.
Like my kids aren't dying in in youth and
my wife's and gonna die in childbirth.
I'm not going to really have
to experience dire poverty.
I can get anything I want from the
comfort of my own home there I have to go
anywhere. Everybody has several cars, I
have entertainment that never ends. Right?
All of this stuff is just fantastic.
And then yesterday I was having,
I was having lunch with a
prominent Hollywood figure
whose name I won't mention,
so he doesn't lose work. And we're doing
it at a, at a restaurant in Brentwood,
and we're talking about Trump and politics
and I was looking around this room
and everybody's drinking $200 bottles
of Chardonnay and then they're,
then they're bubbly water and they're,
and they've got their,
their Kale Salad and the whole thing.
And it occurred to me that 98% of the
people in this room think we are living in
danger of incipient fascism right there.
If you'd pull the room and say,
are we living in crisis mode? 98%
of the people that were and go, yes,
we're living in a crisis while they
sit there chardonnay. Yeah, yeah.
That will then either you're not active
enough or you're just lying to yourself
because you don't actually
think that we're in crisis. Now,
that's not to say that we,
we aren't at crisis point because there's
so many people willing to break the
system.
But I think that one of the things that's
coming true right now is that so many
people think that the system
is irrevocably broken,
that they are willing to break the system,
that he's not a replicable,
sad, essentially bring
on the recess. Yeah.
Because that'll rid of readiness
of Trump. It's like, well,
you want the disease so that you
can have the cure. It's like,
it's just not helpful. Yeah. Well,
yeah, you should sit this one out.
Oh, no, go. No, go for it.
This is the fun. Uh, so I,
I sort of radically disagree.
I think that a lot of the people who
are at the very top understand why these
games are fragile and so the
Games are still serviceable.
But if you actually understand how the
Games are played, you understand, um,
just how quickly this thing could turn.
So I think first of all,
it is precisely the people
with a enough success,
um, because how it shouldn't mean
they would be willing to turn it.
That's the thing. Well,
that's where I don't get the,
the number of people with nine and 10
figures worth of wealth who talk to me
about like the rich and the powerful as
if they are some different groups. Yes,
it's very hot and um,
Rich's richer than me.
That's what I think.
It's,
there's a difference between people who
have their senators on speed dial and
people who don't. So, you know,
the rich is not a monolith and that's one
of the huge problems, uh, in the story.
If,
if you're engaged in some kind of business
like armament or extraction where you
need to have a very close
relationship with government,
you see the world very differently
than if you're very good at picking
investment opportunities and you just
want to be unfettered in your ability to
go to go make more. Um, you know,
I think that one of the things that
really resonates about your message and,
and I feel a little bit less
close to Ben on is, is that, um,
somehow the message that you
should improve your own life got
conflated with if your
own life isn't awesome,
it's because you failed to make it so,
and I think that was the sort of more
true in a period of uniform high growth is
between 1945 and 1970 when,
you know,
if you had Beta to the system,
if you just had exposure
hardwork usually paid off.
I think that depending on what sector
you're in, what your skill set is,
where you are in your life, it's very hard
for some people to turn things around.
And the idea of, look, you may
not be able to solve your problem.
You solve the problems you can front,
but you can solve the portion of the
problems that you can solve yourself and
that you should at least do that.
That is a very different
message because it says,
even if I'm not living in a luxury at
the end of it, it's not because I failed.
And I think that
couple of years distinction and I,
and I, and I would probably, you know,
given that criticism,
I'd probably agree to the curbing
of my own kind of solution. Right?
Like I think that, I think that's
right. Clearly there are people,
we are all created equal rights.
We're not all created equal and our
abilities are in our capacity to rise or
fall in a society sectors
or in terms of our 100% yes.
Yeah. And I would do the
other half of that thing,
which is I would climb down from asking,
you know,
if more people were willing to
admit that, I would say, okay,
it's very important that people at least
make an a copayment of trying to solve
the problems in their own life
before demanding that the, yeah.
Well the [inaudible] and that's the part
that I focused on more simply because I
think that the government is so big.
I mean,
this is where politics and philosophy may,
right?
So I think the government is so big and
so intrusive and so involved in so many
areas of our life that the,
the tendency right now in America is to
blame other people for the problems that
you have. And that's true on
virtually every side of the aisle.
I think that when you, and I have
disagreements about trait theory,
but I think when president Trump goes
to a rust belt town in Ohio and he says,
I'm gonna bring back all your jobs because
the Mexicans or the Chinese screwed
you. I think that that's a, that's a lie.
I don't think he's bringing
back those jobs, disagreeing
about that. Yeah. And so,
and so,
you know,
I think that when my solution to that
is there's not necessarily a solution.
I think one of the,
that there's always a solution to every
problem that can be had if you just have
enough communal power behind
it. And I don't think that's
right. I think that the,
the solution for most problems in life,
not all because I don't think all
problems in life ever get solved,
but at least the majority of the major
mistakes people make in their life that
create obstacles that they can never
overcome the rest of their life are self
inflicted. I think that the, the,
the UN barring health serious health
problems or mental disability,
I think the d the number of problems that
make it impossible for you to overcome
sheer dire poverty in the United States.
Virtually all of those problems are
problems that people put in front of
themselves. And so if you can
make those basic decisions,
they can turn their life around
it and a pretty significant way.
Yeah. Or even if they're not problems
that people create for themselves,
there are problems that are there subject
to that are also very intractable to
communal level solutions.
Like mental illness is a good example
of that and its contribution to
homelessness.
It's like,
well it's terrible to be mentally
ill and to end up on the streets.
It definitely is terrible, but it isn't
like we actually know how to solve that.
So even if that can't be put at the feet
of the individuals who are suffering,
it's like,
okay well we'd like to sort that out.
Community leads party to sort that out
without making it worse. We don't know.
Do you guys think we can only make it a
little better or a little worse? Like,
of course all hell could
break loose on one side of it,
but that within the margins,
like it's pretty good and we can maybe
make it a little better, but that,
that the capacity for humans to make a
system much better than this that will
allow people to flourish works like
that's what I'm hoping is that we can aim
for incremental improvement,
which compounds by the way,
so that that's very powerful,
incremental improvement,
but we could aim for
incremental improvement while
deciding that we're going to
stay off stave off chaotic and unnecessary
descends into the abyss. Right.
Which is what I see the danger in this,
in this polarization processes generating.
It's like a catastrophe
that we actually don't need.
W what do you make of the amount of
people that seem to want that right now?
I mean, I always say every week on this
show it's like Twitter is not real life.
Yeah.
But the amount of people that I'm seeing
constantly talking about tear it down
and now the new attack on civility where
even if you say be civil, be respectful,
that that is now thought of as a tool
of the patriarchy or a tool of the
oppressed or uh, all of that stuff.
What do you make of that assault?
I mean,
I think first of all,
the fun mental hatred of the
system by a lot of people is,
I'm not going to justify it given the
fact that the system that we have is the
best that has ever,
you know,
happen to any human beings in
the history of the world. I mean,
this is a pretty great place to live.
Um, compared to all other, right? Yeah.
That's him. That's him compared
to utopia compared to heaven.
I'm not saying can't get any better.
I think that one of the great
dangers always his utopianism,
and I think you're seeing
it from both sides. I mean,
right now when you saw Alessandra Kazia
Sanchez when in New York and she's
promising universal healthcare,
universal college tuition,
universal universal housing,
right.
All of this stuff is going to magically
happen and she's asked on Msnbc are
going to pay for any of this and she
just basically as well just how FDR did.
FDR didn't, okay. That was one of
the big problems. Yeah and the,
and also there is a giant world war
happening at the time so it's the,
the the itch to [inaudible]
to grow to provide that.
That's the thing that you really,
you really want to,
you want to make a state that has
enough power to grant all those wishes.
It's like careful what kind of genie
you generate cause it's going to have a
demand on you.
So I don't think the market is that
free markets are inherently utopia and I
don't think that a vast government
is inherently, you told me,
but I think free markets at least have
a certain respect for human labor.
Dignity and individuality and collectivist
utopia is certainly do not or they
also have a certain distributed quality.
It's like,
it's not like there's a central
administration making the decisions.
So even if the decisions are bad,
which sometimes they are,
they tend to be self correcting
and mostly the operate locally.
So there's something to be said for that.
So what do you say it
people that are going to listen to
this that I think you're a little more
sympathetic to the that are going but,
but we need help or,
or this is the sounds cold
or to individually apps
is going to be colder than
this.
You guys are like warming my heart.
We hear stories about individuals calling
themself up with their bootstraps.
I mean there was a phase change in the
economy around 1970 that I cannot get
people to focus on. And you
know, if you look at like GDP,
which is a very flawed measure
and median male income,
which Tyler Cowen I think was the one
who pointed out that this is the best
version of the argument. One
of these things, they're,
they're both growing up together until
like 1970 and then one of them flat lines.
And then it keeps going.
And the idea that this is not a
structural change that is in every school
textbook and that we don't understand
that we've built up to plus generations of
experts lying about
what happened and how do you, what
do you think happened? What do you,
why did that, cause I've read
criticisms of the decoupling theories.
Nobody likes my version of it,
but I'll give it,
give it to you cause
I don't understand it.
Everyone who cares about this stuff should
read a guy named Derek to solar price
who was active in the late fifties and
started talking about there will be a
singularity in science. So he looked
at price's law. Yeah. Number of PhDs,
number of journals,
number amount of funding.
Everything was going up exponentially and
things that go up exponentially cannot
continue.
And so he predicted this is going to
end because there will be too many Ph,
you know, too many PhDs per child. Um,
and sure enough that
system sort of came apart.
So if you look at the period from
between 1945 to 1970 you have this growth
regime and everything that
got built during that time
has what I call an ego and
embedded growth obligation.
If it doesn't grow at this rate,
it's going to turn pathological.
And so we built a ton of infrastructure
around this beautiful period of high,
broadly distributed,
fairly even in stable technology,
technologically like growth.
And that ended and then began this crazy
period of excuse making where we found
every gimmick demand. And if you want
to read an article about this call,
I think I wrote one called a anthropic
capitalism in the new gimmick economy.
And so part of the problem is,
is that the concept of jobs as how we
feed ourselves rather than creative
enterprises or something else,
um,
jobs are probably tied to a period of
time that isn't going to go on forever.
And it's probably weakening
as a means of feeding us.
So the market was unbelievably brilliant.
And then there was a structural change.
And now the question is how do we
account for these egos that make embedded
growth obligations that make layers of,
of all of the experts who
service the institutions.
So the big problem that we're having,
the reason we can't wake
up from this madness is,
is that you've had since about 1970
people having to lie to keep the
institutions afloat. So what's
the lie? Well, take a law firm.
The idea is you have some number of
partners. The partners have associates.
All the associates want
to become partners,
so you have to tell them a
story about if you work hard,
you will become partners. But when you
hit steady state like the professors,
the professor wants to have 20 students,
20 students want to become professors,
to have 20 students.
None of this stuff works anymore.
It's a hidden, they call that
game. It's a hidden pyramid scheme,
hidden page and it scheme,
it got come ability levels since 1980.
I've been relatively stable in the United
States while we've been a very rich
family trying to figure out ways to
live out our days in the style to which
we've become accustomed. And we found
every kind of gimmick known demand,
whether it's offshoring or uh, you
know, mergers and acquisitions or,
um, you know, self regulation of markets.
All of these things that we learned how
to do it just the transfer over to the
service economy as opposed to in the
intellectual economy as opposed to
manufacturing. Well, the thing is, is that
a lot of this was led by something like,
you know,
science in the form of let's say,
just semiconductors coming out of
physics. You know, how much of, of,
of our current, uh, growth has been
scientifically led. And now, you know,
with Moore's law,
the reason that everybody talks about
it is it's one of these growth laws that
can't go on forever.
So
do you think doing pretty
well? I mean, part of it,
I know things that are impossible
can't continue forever.
That's the rule of hasn't been
dabbling seems to be one of them.
The ideas that we've been pretty good
staving off disaster for a very long time,
but it seems to me though that
there is like this, and this is,
this is perhaps part of the contradiction
that people are arrested with is like,
ah, you're appointed to two structural
deception, let's say something like that.
And delusion, the delusion that go along
with it. But it also does seem to me,
and this is where the measurement
issues become so complicated,
is that even though wages among men have
been flat since the 1970s I think you
could make a pretty cogent case
that we are actually in many ways,
much richer than we were. First
of all, the world's much richer.
There's much less poverty worldwide,
and in an absolute sense as well.
And so even if the average American
isn't richer, let's say, oh,
although we could dispute that the world
that surrounds him as much richer and
that actually constitutes
a form of accrued wealth
because you're actually safer
when when a quarter of the Chinese aren't
starving in a quarter of the Indians.
Appreciate. Okay. So, but so, but
then I would also say, so there,
although there's been local
stagnation in the west,
arguably there's been global
massive global improvements and,
but then the other question is,
is the idea of local
stagnation actually accurate?
Because there are lots of ways that we
are clearly way richer than we were now.
Um, we're certainly richer in terms of
our access to high quality information at,
at a very,
very low cost.
And so the technological revolution seems
to be real and we can purchase a lot
more of this high quality technology for
less money than we could. So I'm not,
I'm not entirely convinced of the wage
state about the wage stagnation argument.
There's a
tremendous meant to be done, but the
metrics about how we measure things,
there's also a total flaw that
is suffused throughout economics.
I just came back from four days in Venice
and the first day in Venice, I thought,
this place is unreal. The most beautiful
thing I've ever seen in my entire life,
every 52 years didn't prepare me for
four days later. I was like, wow,
there's so many tourists and
took almost no time to remove
that level of magic. Um,
because I got used to it that
quickly. Right? Yeah. Right. Yeah.
Well that's a problem we get. We get
used of the head on it are going well.
Extraordinarily chronic numbing
is a real issue. And the thing is,
is that what were the Gini coefficients
measuring the inequality during the
period that was going up?
You know,
we're now in a period of such
inequality that, um, you know,
humans are very focused on
things like status and CSCS.
And so it's not clear to me that people
wouldn't be actually happier in a
totally different regime. I mean,
we have enough stuff from China.
Exactly right now. In all in all
of that, Mike. Michael. Wow. Okay.
So that's,
that's an interesting issue because one
of the things we could say perhaps is
that between 1945 and 1972 what was
provided for people wasn't so much on a
standard of living that's
higher than we have now,
but a trajectory of development
that appeared more stable,
stable and believable.
And so low variance yet, right? Yes. Well,
so, so, and then the question is, well,
what actually do you want?
Do you want a high standard of living or
do you want to believe that if you put
an incremental effort,
your life can improve and it could easily
be that people will rather have the
ability to make a 30 year
plan. We want the ability, yes.
If what I value the ability to bring a
30 year plan and I want to have some idea
of how I'm going to get to my retirement
and put kids through school and do all
of this and I want them to,
it's this plan. Yeah. Right.
So the idea is that predictability is
gone, no question. And it's right. Right,
right.
That's why I said jobs are not going to
be the means of redistribution of the
wealth. I do wonder if, you know, on the
individual level, I think that that's,
you're right, there's, there's
enormous amount of calves in
volatility in the system and it,
but I think that the only thing that you
can say to that is the same thing that
that's been true for most of
human history. Okay. The, the,
the time when people
could actually stable,
he predict that in 30 years I will be
significantly better off than I am now and
I can make a retirement plan that's
about 50 years of human history. Right?
I mean, before that it was
basically you have two kids,
one of them dies and then
your wife dies in childbirth,
but birth with the second to you have,
you have eight right now you have
eight and six of them die three or
miscarriages in fine.
Yeah. And so, so this,
this dream that we had from 1940 to 1970
even if I actually love the premises,
uh, I'm not sure that that's a realistic
dream about what goes. My point is it,
yeah. So that was the anthropic
capitalism. You just described it.
Now you've got 10 not don't
know for your article, but it's
in a bit more than that.
I mean I'm sure there is and just joking,
but I'm going to make it.
The only point I'm making is that I think
that what really has been lost in this
is the part that, that I'm really
focusing on a lot lately I is,
we can't control the situation around us,
but we can't control our
reactions to the situation.
And what I mean by that is these massive
systemic changes that we're talking
about. We number one, don't agree on what
the systemic changes should be, right?
And number two, even if they are what
they are or what they would do, right,
nobody knows what the hell they would do.
And with all of that said,
the one thing that you can control
is the amount of virtue that you,
yourself pour into your life.
And it seems to me in a non virtuous
position that because somebody else's
earning more than you,
you are therefore worse off.
And so what we really have lost, I
think, and this may be an outgrowth that,
I mean there's,
there's an argument to be made.
I know General Goldberg makes
this argument for example,
but that sort of late stage capitalism
or advanced capitalism tends to, uh,
tends to lead to this rat race where we
are looking at what the guy next door to
us has.
But the,
but the lack of just basic virtue in the
position that I am more soft because my
neighbor is better off even though I have
more stuff than I did five years ago.
Uh,
the lack of inculcation of any sense
of what I would call basic morality is
having a significant impact.
Is it
one of the things that's
happening clearly in, in,
in the tour that I'm doing and the people
that I'm talking to is I'm actually
making a variant of that case.
I said that and, and it's,
it's probably in keeping
with your vision as well. Um,
so let's imagine that a rising tide
does lift all boats and that's actually
happening.
But we're purchasing up that at the price
of a certain degree of predictability
and stability into the future.
That seems quite clear.
And now it's exaggerated by
this incredibly rapid rate
of technological change.
It's like,
okay,
so how do we tolerate all that
uncertainty given that we're also deriving
substantial benefit from it? We don't
want to, we don't want to mess it up.
And what I've been suggesting to my
audiences is get your act together as much
as you possibly can because the way that
you deal with uncertainty is by being
prepared for anything and everything
that's going to come your way.
And so you want to put yourself together
so that when the difficult decisions
come along, even though we
can't predict what they are,
you're going to be in the best
possible as a new message here.
The new message is that whatever,
like I want to tell somebody,
you know,
very
often I hear parents,
like we have uh,
two children and one of them is
living at home. And I say, okay,
let me explain in part why your child
may be living at home when you're
disappointed that that's happening.
Right?
And so I go through the economics are
you, the person feels better. Oh Wow.
Or I explained, you know,
here's why you're not able
to catch up to your parents.
It's not all about your personal failure.
Right?
And so the idea is that that personal
responsibility is something that we need
and we also can't have,
right. It's too dangerous.
You have to do this tailored message.
And I think you've been intuiting this,
like here's the portion of your life that
you're responsible for and we're going
to delineate it.
And if your room isn't cleaned up,
it's not because of the government.
Right. That was your point saying,
and this is, you know, again,
you and I are going to have
to do this at some point.
Um, this is a great country and well,
if you put your mind to making money,
then it may be the case that stick to it.
Agnus and passing the marshmallow test
and being inventive and creative works.
But there are a lot of people who are
given a very different message and they
grow up being told,
you know,
be a good person and work hard and a
lot of the stuff doesn't work the way it
used to. It just doesn't. And
whining about it offends me.
So I want to say,
look,
if making money is very important and we
need to be able to talk about the role
of money, it's money is
fungible. Everything else is
not. So if you make money,
then you have lots and lots of options
and we need to give people the idea that
that's a good thing to pursue
if they have any hope and dream.
But it's also the case that fundamentally
what we are, what your message is,
is you have to make the copay and the
copay is the part of your life that you
absolutely control.
And if that's out of control,
don't expect anyone else to take any
sympathy. Then you can also make them.
If that part of your life is in order,
you can also make a more credible
argument for the existence of unreasonable
systemic impediments. Because
you can say to yourself, look,
I put everything into this group,
then you can make a credible,
this is why this is the,
the attractive version of the personal
responsibility thing that the point we
have it,
we have another problem here with our
discussion about dispossession because
like one of the things that bothered
me about the left and the right is the
right tends to think, well if you just
got your act together and worked hard,
you can make it and the, and the,
and the, the left tends to think,
well everybody's the same.
And if you removed systemic
impediments than everybody could,
could do whatever they needed to do while
the left is wrong because there's real
diversity of ability.
But the right is wrong because
there's a real diversity of ability.
And so for example, there is
a distribution of Iq which
is real. And if you're,
if you're the,
the psychometric data basically indicates
that if you have an Iq of less than 90,
which is about 15 20% of the population,
you actually can't read well enough to
follow instructions. And you might say,
well,
um,
that can be rectified say
through education means and
so forth and the evidence
for that,
it's pretty damn fan.
And so the problem with a society
that's meritocratic fundamentally,
even if it's meritocratic
based on character,
is that they're still going
to be individual differences
that seem to be a Nate
though you're going to produce
radically on equal outcomes,
many of which are painful.
The thing that you will have a hard time
convincing me of having gone through,
uh,
the PHD system in the sciences is that
some of the world's most brilliant people
hold PhDs in the sciences.
And I came up at a time when in the early
nineties these people were told that
the world was their oyster and that we
were desperately in need of scientists.
And I remember a friend of mine being
told that he had a $14,000 a year job
offer post phd from Mit with a pregnant
wife and the person who offered it,
it was like, this is great. We can,
we can, we can get people for pennies.
And why was that?
It was because of something that came
out of the National Academy of Sciences
and the National Science Foundation to
slam American workers in the sector.
This is very,
very important.
It had predicted that people would
be paid six figures for for PhDs,
uh, which was you know, larger than
they had been paid for a long time.
And it was the meddling with the market.
The thing that I don't like about
the personal responsibility issue is,
is that individuals should not be solving
the problems of let's say tech groups
getting together and say we will
not poach each other's employees.
That like the market has to work
for people, not just institutions.
And if you're in a sector in which
you can make the market work for you,
you have this feeling
of anybody can do this.
And in fact what you need to do is you
need to migrate to these sectors because
there are other sectors where you have
let's say government intervention which
says we are going to interfere with the
free working of the market or we are not
going to take into account that
some people produce public goods.
And so it's very important to me to
understand that some people are coming out
of very different circumstances in which
it's very unlikely that they will be
able to make their world, uh, you know,
grow and blossom and that other people
have extraordinary ability and high Iq
and work ethic,
find themselves not fighting forces
that they don't even sort of criticism
that's often levied at me
because people say, well,
you don't take the systemic
problems sufficiently into account.
And so that's a nice outline of
the systemic, you know, when,
when the banks decided that they should
be self-regulating, uh, with respect, uh,
you know, to, to their gearing
ratios or the risk. Um,
there was one guy who wrote in at this
to this sec hearing to allow these
investment banks to, you know, do
the last little bit before 2008, uh,
blew up everything. This guy Len bullae,
who was a computer consultant to banks,
it's like one guy in the entire country
saw a disaster coming and got involved
in this internal game that
was by banks for banks.
And so what's very important to me is
to understand when you have bad behavior
by institutions,
it is pathological to put that
responsibility on shoulders. Well,
the only code I would make to that,
and I think that's a fair comment,
is that what I'm hoping and what I'm
trying to convince people of is that
they're ethical responsibility,
which is partly to further their own
development to the degree that they can,
does extend to the community is that you
want to make ethical citizens so that
they don't make mistakes that corrupt
the operation of the system at a systemic
level. The best way to do that, in
my estimation over the long run,
is to concentrate on the ethical
behavior of the sovereign citizen.
Now that doesn't address the systemic
problems that are already in place.
The systems systems affect more people.
That means that when people make vague
accusations about systems that are
dysfunctional, then it's not
helpful. Know what I see is not,
you're making very specific criterias of
very specific institutions in areas and
those that's useful because then we can
actually have a discussion about where
those systems go wrong.
So you can have it as [inaudible] you're
balancing the patriarchy, right? Exactly.
You can, we can discuss. No, I'm trying
to, I'm trying to crowd that out.
And part of it is, is that
almost nobody in the regular, um,
commentary it wants to talk to me
about what went wrong with
our immigration policy.
How do we get into trouble
with mortgage back securities,
what's going on with CPI adjustment
because I've fortunately we got something
better going on here, so let's not
worry about that. But you know,
we only have about 10 minutes
left because you got a hard out.
So I thought we do a little
self therapy while we're here.
So I want to ask you each one thing,
I'll even answer it myself and then we
can all sort of comment. Uh, I'll, uh,
I'll start there. Um, if
you had one blind spot,
what do you think it might be?
I,
I've asked you guys some version of
all of this before. Um, but you know,
a lot of changes over the
time that we keep doing this.
But if there was something that you
thought was your personal blind spot,
what would it be?
Well, I would say, I don't know if I
can identify a specific blind spot,
but I can say in general,
you know,
I know perfectly well that I don't know
enough about a lot of the things that I
need to know about to make the sorts
of arguments that I make it like I'm
painfully aware and increasingly aware,
I would say,
of of just how much,
I don't know how much more I need to be
reading and concentrating on to flesh
out what I have to say.
Like, I don't know,
I don't know enough about economics,
barely anything.
I don't know a lot about history,
And so I'm more and more aware
of how much I don't know.
And now I don't know if that's the kind
of blind spot that you were thinking of,
but, but, but it, it,
it, it's terrifying to,
to comprehend that and still try to
move forward in this sort of space.
It makes it tough to be a
public person these days. Right?
Because everyone wants you
to know everything about
everything, all the problems
that Eric was just describing,
which is, you know,
the reason that people won't contend with
you is because you forced them to move
from their low resolution ideological
uncertainties into domains where specific
knowledge is necessary. You instantly
exposed everyone's ignorance.
It's like that's,
that's hard on the people that
you're having the discussion with.
But the devil is in the details.
Until the last sentence.
I would say that I would
love you to shorten that and
put it on a bumper sticker
for me. It was a brilliant summary.
Yeah. Blind spots. Shapiro. I mean,
I find it hard to argue with, with
any of that. I think that, you know,
if you're intellectually curious,
then that means that you know,
that you don't know anything. Um, so I, I
agree with, with everything you just said.
I mean, as far as other intellectual
blind spots, I mean, uh,
or other blind spots generally.
I would say that for me the
constant struggle is I find
myself more stressed out
now than I was two years ago when no
one gave a crap when I thought, right.
I mean, that's so, so the fact is
that I, it's, you know, living a,
a less stressful life in the middle of
believing that people actually care what
you think it means. You have to
take your stuff much more seriously.
That's not really a blind
spot as much as a concern. Uh,
and I think that that means that, you
know, just the, the commitment to,
to hearing more about things is,
is deeply necessary.
But it also means that
it just means that you,
your life in many ways is more miserable,
more people know about you.
And it's not a poor me thing. I love what
I do. I love the fact that people care.
And I think like that's what I live.
But it wasn't really, I mean it's,
it's pretty sweet. You got a lot
of good stuff going on. No, I got,
I got a ton of great stuff going on, but
the fact is that I spent, I spent the,
the risk is higher then in some
ways that makes you a better person.
It's almost like the, you know, the, the,
the old kind of religious Logan that
if you feel God is watching you all the
time, then you're more likely
to, to be a better person.
And there is that feeling like,
okay, if I make a mistake,
I'd want to be the first person to notice
that I made the mistake and correct
that mistake.
But that also means that you live with
a lot more self doubt and a lot more
second guessing of yourself and you did
a, you know, when nobody cared. So it's,
so that, that's not as much
of a blind spot is concerned.
The problem with trying to identify your
own blind spots that they're in your
blind spot. Um, but it's,
that's why I asked the question I
wanted to make you pick a little bit.
It's funny because just the other day
it was yesterday actually I did the Adam
Carolla podcast, which he's, you know,
it's comedy and he's doing more of a radio
show thing so you speak a little more
freely and I was about to say something
very politically incorrect and I
obviously don't have a
problem doing that generally,
especially when I'm doing comedy and just
for a moment I had you sort of ringing
in my head about be careful about
your words and I was like, ah,
I just don't feel like offering up
one extra kind of fun that way. Right,
because like the stuff that you
felt like you could say a year ago,
now you realize not only maybe you
shouldn't have said it a year ago,
but also you feel like if I, if
am I, you're constantly saying,
am I curbing myself because I'm afraid
or am I cribbing myself because it's the
right thing to do to curb myself here?
And that's an interesting sort of
calculus you have to do all the time.
If you're concerned that
it's because of fear,
then you might want to take the risk of
saying it. You know, cause I've, I've,
I've tried, wrestled with that
problem is like, you know,
or maybe am I avoiding this because I
think it's better because I don't want to
take on the responsibility.
If you have suspicions about that,
then you should do it
because I think you should,
I should think you should arm yourself
against your weaknesses and take that
risk. I think it's better
developmentally to do that. All right.
I'll answer or answer it for myself,
which is a cue off
something your brother said
to me one shoe, which is, uh,
that perhaps I have a
little PTSD from the left.
So my focus on these completely
bananas ideas has been,
has been so singularly stuck in my mind
that maybe let some other things slide
every now and again. I'm trying to be
very aware of that and trying to, uh,
figure out how to go forward on that show.
Does that mean you're a little bit more
on the attack then you'd like to be?
Because I think I want to ease up on
a little bit of the attack on that.
I think I've spent the last couple of
years really it was first me identifying
it for myself.
Really.
I was interviewing all of these people
and figuring out that they were often
going through the same thing I was, but
then it morphed into going on the attack.
Got It.
And now I feel like because,
and again I say the word winning with
you know a little tongue in cheek,
but because I do send something
has turned here, that may be,
I can get my foot off the gas a little
bit on that and focus on the big ideas
that I really care about that in
relationship to this whole group.
It might be nice.
I think we should really be careful
to use minimum necessary forest. Yeah,
there's, there's idiocy on the left
and on the on the extreme right.
That needs to be pointed out,
but it might be better if
we did the minimum necessary
amount of that because it
also starts to become same.
Something you can parody quite easily
at some point and more and more of
delineating what the alternative might
be if there was a positive alternative.
Right.
Cause it's like you see that it will be
interesting to see what happens with the
IDW as it moves beyond the
critique because what's
really unified as I think has
been a lot the critique
intersectionality and identity politics.
And once we move into the space where
we're actually trying to maybe build
something together or come to some
sort of ideological continents, uh,
then some of these, some of these
healthy, what I hope is the difficult,
we capitulate the arguments.
I hope that recapitulate the
arguments and more reasonable,
cogent and intelligent way. Uh, you know,
in terms of the actual political
arguments. But I'm not sure that those,
I think that none of us,
I hope are dreaming that
there will actually be an
ideological continents among
the lot of us. It was clearly
that is something that that
is not going to happen.
I mean,
we all have significant disagreements
among ourselves on all of these issues.
But how beautiful that is,
that we're all kind of working
through it in our own way and we're,
we're all not going to get
to the exact same ending,
but we'll kind of go with each other
the whole time. Blind spot done.
Oh my gosh. Uh, it's more
or less infinite. Um,
I think that I do a terrible job of,
um,
when somebody is making
a bed analytic argument,
but as intuitive their way
to the right conclusion,
I tend to discount them as if
the analytic argument was how,
how they should be thinking. So
different kinds of minds, um,
who have their variables.
You know, if you've,
if you think nothing of Myers Briggs,
it should at least tell you that there
are kinds of minds that aren't working at
all. Like yours. Big Five
might be a little bit better.
So that's been a huge blind
spot. I think that, um,
I am very focused on provable,
um,
institutional betrayal,
which I can point at and no one else
seems to want to talk about and that
because no one wants to talk about
a really specific problems with the
institutions.
Um,
it leads me sometimes to
not seeing the generic case.
I think that I am very much a
prisoner of my learning disability.
I had to sort of construct
my own operating system to
get around them. Otherwise,
if you ever want to see something funny,
asked Bret Weinstein to read aloud, um,
because you could,
you just see that he's
having to impressionistically
figure out what's on the
page because he's not tracking it.
Exactly. So I think that, um, you know,
that fight, uh, to say I'm not stupid, uh,
probably distorted me a great deal.
I'm having to build my own architecture.
Uh,
and I think,
I think we can safely say are not
stupid. So I think one last thing. Yeah.
And I think that one of the things
that are most worried about is that I'm
fighting the supposedly empathic army
of people trying to destroy conversation
itself has had a very negative impact on
my empathy for exactly the people that
they want me to have empathy for.
And I think that it's very important
for all of us, um, to say, okay,
what's the steel manning of that position?
And to make an extra effort when people
are making absolutely non empathic
arguments,
trying to destroy you and fry you to
think about the empathy that you want to
have for whatever went wrong in their
lives. Might be fun at some point. Um,
to conjure up a panel where some of the
people that are in this group take the
leftist position and defend it
in every possible way, you know,
right from the postmodern conclusions,
which you know, I think are are worthy
of substantial skepticism to the,
to the notion of the reality of the
dispossessed and they and the presence of
systemic oppression
and all of that and to,
and to make the cases as as brutally as
we possibly can with acquity useful like
another I will, I will
not steal man, those tech,
not the tactics we have to come
with you because then we could,
cause it doesn't seem like we've been
able to have the debate with anybody who
can carry the debate. So it
might be really useful to
it and I have been trying,
but it's,
it's,
it's hard because we're spending
most of our energy fending off by,
I think we've all tried, attacked the
tactics. That's exactly the point.
It's not the conclusions. All
right, we got to move on. Jordan.
I or are going to a long beach tonight.
You're going to San Francisco,
you're going back to daily wire.
You guys are doing something for July 4th,
July 4th of July 2nd, we're
going to be doing a, a,
a special episode of daily wire
backstage. That's me. That's a,
God can't share every boring who runs
the place. Uh, it is, um, the x scribble,
Michael Knowles,
Andrew Klavan and Jordan Peterson.
We're all going to be celebrating 4th of
July with everyone's favorite Canadian.
So Jordan's going to stop by at at
4:00 PM Pacific, 7:00 PM Eastern.
So check out daily wire.com for all
that you can check it out at youtube and
Facebook as well. Links down below
and see you tonight. And Long Beach.